it's great to be joined today by Fabio
zoffie who is president and executive
chairman of ORS group which is an
international artificial intelligence
and software company I've had the
pleasure of speaking with Fabio a little
bit before the interview and like me he
shares my passion for entrepreneurship
and small business and the creation of
innovative project so I think maybe
that's a good place to start Fabio I'd
love to hear about a Rs group and what
you're doing really to promote
entrepreneurship and small business ok
hi David hi everybody my name is Fabio
Sophie I'm Italian by birth and Venetian
and I've been living in Germany for the
last 25 years I'm here today as the
president and executive chairman of RS
group which is an international software
company what we do it's a software
company with 20 years of experience and
we use science so mathematics artificial
intelligence and many other fields of
science and create software solutions
which are sold to business customers
enterprises both large ones and small
ones to automate and run efficiently
business processes so that's what we do
and when you say business processes that
can mean very different things for very
very large corporations compared to a
small business or a start-up so what
what do you mean when you say business
processes
yes well the advantage we have is that
you know if we if you have 20 years of
development now we had the chance of
entering many many verticals and
covering now all key business processes
supply chain logistics manufacturing
retail sales finance energy distribution
and the likes with a real customer so
let me give you a few examples of the
things we do basically what we do is the
following we model a process and the
more complex that process is the more
value we can extract
then we collect data the big data from
Europe you system and from public
databases or from the internet and then
we run algorithm so we have scientists
and developers we are over 1,000
proprietary algorithms or dynamic
pricing or supply chain management
optimization so we make value chains
very efficient up to full automation and
so far we've been working with very
large corporations we have companies in
almost any industry and last year we
decided to enter the blockchain
community and connect our artificial
intelligence solutions with blockchain
because it makes a lot of sense that
maybe I will tell you later a little bit
about this and then we discovered that
we realize that these technologies we
are connecting and by the way they are
call I'm calling them the new digital
alphabet ABC somehow too good to be true
so a like artificial intelligence or
algorithms be like law chaining see like
cryptocurrency and all we connect all
together these three technologies and
can't make them available to very small
entrepreneurs even to start the
companies to become very efficient and
very competitive against the big guys so
that's something probably you would like
to know to know more in a while well I'd
like to go in the direction to find out
a little bit about your philosophy on
artificial intelligence in the last
three to five years we've seen
everything from basically whole cloth
acceptance of AI all the way to very
very stark warnings about artificial
intelligence in the context of jobs and
employment as well as even more broadly
you know fears about artificial
intelligence becoming self-aware and
evil to some degree to sort of character
characterize it what's your view about
what's your philosophy I guess about
artificial intelligence in the context
of employment of humans yes my idea is
very similar to nah
other people's idea and so I'm very much
convinced that in two to three decades
from now robots and artificial
intelligence will run almost any
business this is happening it is
happening quicker faster and faster and
so the question is as a society we will
have 10 billion people what kind of jobs
we can offer to 10 million people and in
my view in my understanding the new jobs
will be for scientists quantum
physicists people able to develop and
program robots and bio engineers and all
the jobs where today will be substituted
very likely by robotics and science and
artificial intelligence so a few people
are claiming that because in the past we
were able we were always able to create
more new jobs than the ones we destroyed
right that this time is going to be the
same and my opinions differ my opinion
is that this time is different
as the saying goes because the example
and can make you is that you know once
you could take in the past you could
take someone working at Ford on cars and
retrain pretty quickly this person to
maybe mount solar panels ok these days
in the next 20-30 years we will need to
retrain lawyers auditors consultants so
white-collar jobs into scientists and we
know that is not very likely that we can
transform 10 billion people into
scientists and it takes 20 years to turn
a brain into a scientific brain so I
have two children unfortunately probably
they will not very likely become
scientists so what is the solution
and so what I'm observing is that a lot
of people are worried
Steven Oken unfortunately is not with us
any longer I would love to meet him
he was very worried his idea was that
well the risk is that robots will even
kill human beings then you have someone
like Ray Kurzweil very well known in
Silicon Valley his solution is that we
should merge with robots and become
cyborgs I'm not sure this is going to
happen that fast at least and then you
have you know a guy like Elon Musk
telling that we should escape to Mars
and leave earth to the robots and I'm
joking telling that that's not precisely
my kind of landscape and you have Bill
Gates proposing to introduce taxation on
robots I think that theoretically that
could be working but we were not able as
a society to introduce a worldwide
taxation of financial transaction so I
think it is going to be very difficult
to tax robots and the owners of robotic
plans and then you have the politicians
suggesting universal basic income which
honestly I don't think it's a good
solution just to give like the drug from
the state to keep people at barely
financially surviving level that's the
whole thing I mean I've talked about ubi
quite a bit and I think that there's
definitely I feel like the we've clear
people who support ubi have clearly
identified an impending problem which
you and I would probably agree with I
have a concern that ubi won't actually
be the solution I'm not against it but I
think in a vacuum it's just simply not
going to be a solution to what's coming
I agree with you David I think we might
be smart as a society and introduced a
pezzi level like basic health care basic
insurance basic energy for all
households as a sort of universal basic
income for everyone you know we don't
want to where people not working at all
and also barely financially surviving so
I have a solution what I dare to tell
that have a solution I'm a businessman
so my solution is that if we can turn
people to intrapreneurs to billions of
entrepreneurs we will automatically be
changing society bottom ah no so my idea
is that too if we can empower through
technologies startup companies young
people the new generation to easily
become intrapreneurs and to be
successful entrepreneur small
entrepreneurs because they can be as
efficient as the Amazon of this world
then once you know you you have so many
entrepreneurs small entrepreneurs we
will change society because they will be
financially independent they will be
free
I say it's free in the spirit and in the
mind and they will be well they will be
voting for very different politicians so
my idea and by the way I want to tell
you that what did this was last year
discovery for me on my own personal
journey as a businessman that I can use
the business where I screw not only for
doing some business but also for
contributing changing society for the
better so and that's what we are doing
with the merging with blockchain with
the ICO we are doing in making all of
our algorithms available to developers
entrepreneurs worldwide and empowering
them to become very successful in what
they do even if they are very small
entrepreneurs and I think that we can do
that so my vision is to empower 1
billion entrepreneurs by 2014 together
with a lot of other intelligent people
and like-minded and so we can use
technologies for improving society so
this is a very positive way of seeing
technology which is now as cheap as it
never was and that's what we are doing
so we've been speaking with Fabio Jaffe
who is president and executive chairman
of
our s group we are going to be getting
into the details of the actual ICO and
platform in a future video for now Fabio
where can people learn more about ORS
group and what you're doing mm-hmm yes
we have two websites one for the project
of merging artificial intelligence with
blockchain and for D ratio which is
www-where s group dot IO and then we
have our official website or artificial
intelligence based solutions which is
wwws dot say I
Fabio thank you so much for talking to
me today
thank you David my pleasure imagine a
world where everyone has the opportunity
to succeed a world in which a return to
equilibrium is possible where anyone is
able to use technology for creating a
better future for themselves their
family and the community regardless of
their country of origin and social
status
in the next few decades the technology
dominance by a few large corporations
and individuals could fuel inequality
even further the alternative the real
progress is in the return to a
decentralized world where billions of
entrepreneurs can use digital innovation
to win back personal and collective
freedom at ORS group we have developed a
digital ecosystem to empower small
entrepreneurs the ABC technology
building blocks artificial intelligence
blockchain and cryptocurrency the new
alphabet for assisting you in the
construction of your business to
successfully compete against bigger
players you can dream globally while
acting locally algorithms will help you
with all types of forecasts and decision
making blockchain can provide
transparency and cooperation and
cryptocurrency can free you from the
constraints of the traditional financial
system and ORS group we dare to dream
about changing the world through
technology our vision is to empower 1
billion small entrepreneurs by 2040
through artificial intelligence and
blockchain enabling you to better adapt
to a radically changing economy
because financially independent people
are free in their life and mind we are o
are s group for choice for a brave new
world
[Music]